[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um um
um um
foreign
[Music]
city of dream
hello and welcome to episode 2 of night
city wire
this is the show from us at cd projekt
red where we talk about
all things cyberpunk 2077
in today's episode we're going to be
deep diving into lifepass and showing
you a brand new gameplay video
as well as having a chat to philip from
our quest team
then we're going behind the scenes and
taking a look at how i refused to
bringing the band samurai to life
and then we're showing you another new
gameplay video
and having a chat pavel our senior
gameplay designer
about just some of the tools of
destruction that'll be at your disposal
in night city
so let's get started street kid nomad or
corporal
which will you pick first
[Music]
well who do we have here
grew up in haywood whole street was my
family
neighbors helped each other out thought
nothing of it
i'm pleased to see you have enough
forgotten dudes
born here live here die here
childhood memories hopping buildings
running away from badges iron taste of
blood from a split
got everybody fighting for a slice of
the street get the [ __ ] out of vista
keep getting jumped you find some
stronger tubers
do you want to spend the rest of your
days blasting scabs
or become a legend overnight
we have a ride the major
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
come on
my childhood let's see
racing my bobber for the first time
through the hills
oh and uh first kiss in the middle of a
synth cornfield
[Music]
we nomads choose who to make our family
a choice forges strong bonds and a
higher duty that stands solid as an old
oak
my family's in pieces that's why i'm
headed for night city
makes you an outcast among outcasts
miss this you know camaraderie
i know i saw it in your heart the first
time you met
know what i always liked about nomads
your taste
no hunger for freedom not easy to come
by in night city
corpse got their grubby claws and
everything
i have those reports you asked for they
were supposed to be ready yesterday
the world's going to tear us apart when
the word gets around
the world's never going to find out
if i go down you're going down with me
no i'm not [ __ ] joking this isn't a
request
v but no way you're [ __ ] right
you're the one who fixes other people's
[ __ ] if you work in our soccer counter
intel
you're always [ __ ] today
they got you to zero somebody
tomorrow i'll get somebody else to zero
you
what's the rules jack i want to be top
got to have some skin in the game yeah
but you're not on top it's a borough
and you're the pendejo keeps in there
work for yourself
live for yourself that's the only way
philip it is so good to see you again
it's actually been a while since i've
had a chance to interview you about
cyberpunk
so i think for today we'll start with a
question that everybody wants to know
how does the path you pick affect your
time in night city
it actually affects your time quite a
lot throughout the whole game but let's
start at the beginning because basically
our game
has three different starts depending on
your life path
as an example if you choose the street
kid life path you have lived most of
your time in night city
you know the streets you know the gangs
you know the slang you kind of know
what's going
on in the let's say lower life aspects
of the city
which can of course give you lots of
good opportunities also later on in the
game
but if you start as a nomad you actually
used to be part of a nomad clan and a
nomad family
because nomads that roam the deserts
around night city
that we call the badlands actually value
their family above anything
but for one reason or another you
actually left that family behind
and now the beginning of the game for
you will actually be
how to get into night city and how to
make a new life there
then you can also choose to actually be
a corporal and choose the corporate life
path
and that basically means that you're not
at home in the streets of night city
or in the deserts of the badlands but
actually inside the boardroom
because you roast the corporate ladder
of the arasaka corporation
which basically gives you the ability to
sometimes you know read between the
lines
read people when they're trying to do
business which of course can give you
many nice opportunities later on
so this isn't just about the start of
the game can you maybe
help people understand how this
translates into the gameplay
yeah so the thing is we make cyberpunk a
real
rpg and part of that is that you can
play your character
from the start to the end and of course
you know we have these life paths
affecting the beginning of the game
but we wanted to make it so you have
your life path opportunities
throughout the whole game until the game
is over
and as an example we do that by giving
you additional options in dialogues
so i can give you one specific example
and this is a mission where you have to
steal a flathead robot
from the maelstrom gang basically those
maelstromers
stole that flathead before from a
corporate transport
and the owner of that corporate
transport meredith stout
wants you to do something else and this
is an optional objective
and even within that objective we want
to give you some options
so as an example if you have a corporate
life path you basically know what
meredith stout is really about you can
read between the lines
and you can get some additional options
that maybe actually later
enable you to do a completely different
thing with the maelstrom gang
and if you're a nomad you know exactly
some more details about how these
maelstromers
would have even been able to steal a
robot like that from meredith stout
who's part of the very powerful militech
corporation
as a street kid we as an example don't
give you a specific
new dialogue option in that dialogue
because as a street kid
you do not have a lot of experience
dealing with higher up people like
meredith stout
but we want to give you additional
options that fit your life path very
well
so later when you actually talk to the
maelstrom gang one member of the gang
offers you some
illegal substance but as a street kid
you actually know what this is about you
can talk some shop with him
and that might actually make that
character like you a little bit more
so philip i do have a couple of extra
questions for you based on the video we
just saw
and the first is about nomads so the
nomad life path
this starts in a place called the
badlands is this somewhere you get to
visit
even if you don't pick nomad to start
with yes absolutely
so the thing is night city is surrounded
by this huge landscape
that we call the badlands and you can go
there whenever you want so as an example
if you actually do play the nomad life
path at the start and you are in the
badlands
you can even see night city on the
horizon and
we want to give you the option later in
the game if you want you can just take
your car
and drive out of the city you can go
there whenever you want
thing is you might not want to because
the badlands can be a pretty dangerous
place at first
because time has not been very kind to
the badlands
there have been many wars in the past
there's global warming
so most people that do live out there
don't really have another choice about
it
or are nomads that love this life and
are all about it and are very battle
hardened
we of course also want to tell their
stories because we want to tell
many many different stories throughout
the cyberpunk genre
which means that you will also find
missions that lead you out in the
badlands
or where you deal with the people living
there so philip can you tell us a little
bit more about the character padre
he's the guy we see giving his business
card to street kid v
in the video who is this man yeah so
potter is actually one of the fixers in
night city
and fixers are people that work as
intermediaries
so if someone who has a lot of money
needs a problem solved they go to a
fixer
and a fixer then finds people who can
solve that problem and these people are
people like you
the cyberpunks fixers are very
territorial so padres specifically works
from haywood
which is where you as a street kid grew
up in so you already know him
you might have already seen another one
of our fixers who is called dexter
deshawn
and he works in a different part of the
city so specifically padre you might
know him as a street kid
but even if you played other life paths
you might sooner or later meet him
because he's operating in haywood which
is a pretty big place
with many good jobs so if you want to
make some cash there
you will sooner or later deal with padre
philip thank you
so much for joining us now on my first
playthrough
pretty sure i'm gonna be picking nomad
but for those watching we would love to
know what you'll be picking so have a
think about it
and send us a tweet don't forget that
later in this episode we're going to be
showing you another
new gameplay video and having a chat to
pavel our senior gameplay designer
about just some of the tools of
destruction that'll be at your disposal
in night city
but before that let's talk about music
because music plays a huge
part in bringing night city to life now
in future episodes we're going to talk
about things like radio stations and
even the original score
but today we're going to take a look
behind the scenes that our refused to
bring in johnny silverhand's band
samurai to life
i wouldn't write these lyrics for myself
so it's kind of interesting to to get
into like
the mindset of who is this character and
what would they write about
what what's their agenda
[Music]
it's interesting to to try to like catch
a language that
that's his and try to catch a language
that's like
part of this game
[Applause]
there is a reason why we're here
[Music]
it was piotr maybe who was a fan of the
band
he knew refused and he knew my voice and
he said oh that's a perfect voice for
for johnny
and that they wanted i guess a sound
that was a bit contemporary from when
it's
when johnny is supposed to have had the
band because he's sort of like an
anti-establishment kind of guy gonna
drag a corporal rat on stage
make him kneel douse it with gas then
light them up so of course there are
things that you can relate to and like
just like this outcast and this rebel
that's fighting against like the
the corporals and that's definitely
something that's been a part of my life
and a part of refused life we came out
of the punk rock scene of
northern sweden he's like the future
version of us
[Music]
so i think it makes sense i think it
totally makes sense for us
to be here making these songs about him
or for him you know so it's pretty cool
yeah no no no no
but yeah but like white vibrato
[Applause]
[Music]
we don't have a different mode than just
going all
in so we really work on these songs
trying to make them as good as possible
then they're not actually our songs it's
interesting as
as a musician to play another musician
because that's essentially what we're
doing i mean we're not here as refused
we're here
samurai and i'm here with johnny sylvan
you know so it's like the voice we're
representing here is someone else
it's been a mind [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get down
[Music]
i mean the shouting in itself is just
like second nature to me because i've
been i've been doing this for a very
long time
but then when someone comes in and says
i'm happy with everything except for as
a limb
again it's as a as a
okay the shouting is great but think of
that accent so think of that like
enunciation
it's a bit weird because it is it's a
very different way of singing
when you're screaming like that and it's
hard to sort of keep
swallowing some syllables there adjust
your accent
oh yeah just try it again so it's been a
bit
frustrating it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't horrible but it wasn't great
but i mean i get it i mean we
we have to maintain the illusion that
this character that's a character of the
game also is me
like when i'm singing it so it makes
sense but yeah it's a bit
different to have someone telling you
exactly how to
announce these things because i'm not
used to usually people are just like
give me a thumbs up and then like you
know
you think the things like the rhythm and
you think about the pitch and you think
about all these things but then
someone comes in and like that word
sounded weird i'm like what no
that's how i sing but so it's been a
very uh
yeah very painful at times
but it's all right see this soon i'm
chipping in
roll the boots
it's a very interesting thing to be part
of as
as a person that's not a gamer i don't
think i fully understand the impact that
this might have
if people like these songs and if people
are excited
then that's gonna be great i mean we are
spending a lot of time
trying to get this right try and get it
to sound like you know
like samurai would sound you know so
it's it's quite interesting it's a very
different way of
of making music actually
you can already find three samurai
tracks available on streaming services
chipping in never fade away and the
ballad of buck ravers
but we're excited to announce a fourth
new song
called a like supreme which is coming to
streaming services
today that means you can check it out
once the show is over
don't forget that if you're tuning in
late or if you just want to watch
anything again
we will be uploading everything to our
channel soon
next up pavle and i are going to
introduce you to some
creative ways that you can solve
problems in night city
[Music]
av i have a job for you
a client of mine is making an arms deal
he needs
protection it could get hot
very hot the gun dealers on maelstrom
alas nothing ever transpires us
with them you better gear up for this
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh
put my weight on you and tell me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
soviet are you willing
yeah i'm in
pavel thank you so much for joining me
now there was an
awful lot in that video right because
it's more than just guns
absolutely we have melee weapons we have
ranged weapons we have cyber where we
have
offensive cyberwear defensive cyber
armor
we could talk for hours and hours about
this stuff
i think just for today's episode we
should keep it simple and let's just
talk about
guns can you tell us uh the different
types of guns that will be in the game
so we have three distinct types of guns
in our game we have
power weapons we have tech weapons and
we have smart weapons
now power weapons are the most similar
to contemporary weapons
one thing they can do which normal
weapons cannot is ricochet bullets off
of surfaces
so you can hit somebody hiding behind
cover or hiding behind a wall
now tech weapons on the other hand use
electromagnetic power to propel
a fully metal projectile to extreme
velocities
what that allows them to do is to punch
through cover or punch to walls
to hit somebody who's not even aware
that you're there
smart weapons use guided missile
technology to actually track targets in
real time
so you can hit somebody who's dodging
running away from you
or you can hit somebody who's hiding
behind cover
so pavel cyberpunk doesn't just contain
fps elements like it's also a fully
fledged rpg
so can you tell us how you guys
approached introducing those rpg
elements into gunplay
so i can tell you one thing holly it
wasn't easy to merge those two elements
together
now we've spent a considerable amount of
time
merging the rpg and fpp side of our game
what the player will experience is that
v
changes from a small time mercenary to a
legend in the world of night city v
becomes
more and more proficient in using
weapons as the game progresses so they
will see that
reload times become shorter the accuracy
of your weapons grows
you will have faster aiming time you
will move faster with your weapons
everything becomes more in your control
and that gives you
more opportunities to defeat the biggest
encounters that we've designed for you
so i have prepared a few extra questions
for you pavel if you're feeling up to it
of course okay well the first is gonna
be how do you
find more weapons in night city like
where will players be looking for them
so i expect the players to look
everywhere for
new and exciting weapons you can of
course buy weapons at vendor shops
and they will house an entire catalogue
of weaponry that you can get
however the best weapons that you can
find will be
taken from enemies or loot caches that
we have
everywhere in night city the weapons
rarities range from
common to uncommon up to rare and then
legendary
and as they go in rarity they actually
climb in power
however legendary weapons are very
specific
in such a way that they possess unique
abilities that you will find on no other
weapons in the game
the players will actually need to make
some tough
choices to find some legendary weapons
because maybe they need to
choose whether to kill a person who
holds the legendary weapons that they
want
or to spare them because they like them
as a character
so next question let's talk about weapon
modifications
what mods can people give to their
weapons in night city
so we have two types of modifications in
the game one of them would be
modifications that we call attachments
so these would be scopes and silencers
and you can see them
actually being attached to your weapon
as you're playing the game they give you
statistics advantage and they give you
more opportunities in gameplay
the other part of modes would be
software modes
now these are basically small chips that
you install in the
in your weapon and they actually change
the statistics of the gun
they can give you damage they can give
you accuracy or they can give you
more fire rate some of those mods
actually change the
gun play on a more fundamental level so
they can give you non-lethal rounds
biochemical rounds to tear through that
armor
even faster so i suppose for my final
question
uh why don't you tell us about your
favorite weapon then which is your
favorite weapon so far in night city
oh there are so many weapons that it's
hard to choose just
one but i can mention some manufacturers
with their weapons that i absolutely
adore the first manufacturer would be
tsunami defense systems
who produces the sniper rifle nekomata
that's a tech sniper rifle that means
that it can pierce through walls
so you can actually hit somebody who's
hiding behind cover
or who doesn't even know you're there of
course i also like a close quarters
approach
and what that needs is a shotgun one of
the shotguns that we have in the game is
budget arms carnage
now that thing is cast from pure steel
and it weighs a ton
however you can cut a person clean in
half with it
another shotgun that i absolutely love
it's for a more refined approach i would
say
is a smart shotgun that thing has eight
barrels
and that means it can track eight
targets independently
now killing an entire room was never
simpler
uh pavel thank you so much for joining
me thank you for having me
uh i'm actually pretty interested to see
what kind of weapons people discover
when they
play cyberpunk for themselves before we
end
episode 2 this is a reminder that those
who wish to dive deeper into the law
can now pick up the world of cyberpunk
2077.
this is a brand new book created in
collaboration with
darkhorse books that will give you an
extensive look
at what makes night city tick before
jumping into the game
this november that is it for today's
episode thank you so much for joining us
don't forget that if you've missed
anything or if you just want to watch
again we will be uploading everything to
our channel shortly
thank you so much for tuning in and
we'll be back with
night city wire episode 3 soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
c
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]